[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installments of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be covering
the five most powerful defensive spells
in the harry potter universe i made a
video covering the eight
most powerful offensive spells months
ago so i figured it made sense to do the
same thing for the spells
on the other side of the spectrum let me
reiterate this list will not include any
offensive spells
like vladikadavra fiendfire etc
purely defensive magic will be featured
and these spells will be ranked in terms
of
maximum defensive capability and
usefulness
comparing spells can sometimes be
difficult particularly as in harry
potter we haven't actually been able to
witness first
hand the effects of defensive spells
against various offensive spells
additionally the properties of
individual spells are usually very
unique
and these differences make them hard to
compare where one spell might be
extremely powerful in one circumstance
it might be useless in another but i'll
try my best to consider this when i'm
ranking them
the list will feature both defensive
spells that one might use in a combat
scenario
as well as more protection based spells
that one might cast in order to ward off
an imminent threat
i'm not going to include spells like the
disillusionment charm
or the fidelius charm as that just
avoids combat altogether
that's not what i'm going for
additionally this list reflects my
own opinion these rankings are not set
in stone and i'd love to hear what your
top five defensive spells
would look like if you come up with your
own then comment it down below
and if you agree with mine then let me
know number five
impedimenta aka the impediment jinx
swift use of this jinx can freeze an
attacker for a few moments
or stop a magical beast in its tracks
the jinx is a vital part of any
duelist's arsenal
that quote is from miranda goshawk's
book of spells an essential component of
the hogwarts student curriculum
and it couldn't be more right
impedimenta is truly a must-have
for a combat prone witch or wizard the
impediment jinx is used to slow or stop
a target in its tracks
which can provide any witch or wizard
with extra time to consider their
options
in a combat scenario hermione openly
expressed her appreciation
for the spell i like the look of this
one this impediment jinx
should slow down anything that's trying
to attack you harry we'll start with
that one
and harry upon learning it ends up using
it a ton of times
the spells show up numerous times in the
triwizard tournament
battle of the seven potters battle of
the astronomy tower
battle of the department of mysteries
the little hangelton graveyard
and more the spell is truly vital and
with death eaters chasing you
i'm sure you wouldn't pass up an
opportunity to slow them down
number four fianto durie and repelo
minikum i know what you're thinking
that's two spells but
hear me out vianto durie and rappello
anim
go hand in hand and are often paired
together they go like spaghetti and
meatballs
like butter and popcorn they are a
package deal in the films
both spells are cast by flitwick
slughorn and molly weasley
when setting up protective enchantments
around hogwarts these protective
enchantments were set up in advance of
the battle of hogwarts
and given what was on the line the lives
of students and the protection of the
school
i'm willing to bet that these spells are
nothing to scoff at these spells which
were also paired with protego maxima set
up a protective shield around the
perimeter
the school that stopped any unwanted
visitors from getting in
the shield produces a bluish white light
and disintegrates any unwanted visitors
on the spot if they come into physical
contact with it spells that hit the
shield produce
large resonating explosions but unless
they are extremely powerful
won't be able to break through in harry
potter countless death eaters and
snatchers
were bested by this shield and it was
not until lord voldemort came along
that the shield was eventually taken
down the apparent effort
exhausted by voldemort in an effort to
take the shield down is a testament to
its power and durability
number three expelliarmus coming in at
number three on the list is expelliarmus
okay i know what you're thinking
expelliarmus isn't that just a disarming
child that's taught to members of the
dueling club at hogwarts
the answer to that is yes however it's
also the spell that harry uses to defeat
lord voldemort
the name expelliarmus comes from the
latin word expeller
which means to drive away and armor
which means weaponry
expelliarmus was taught to students in
the dueling club in the great hall
as well as in the room of requirement
when harry taught it to members of
dumbledore's army
harry who frequented the spell was a
strong proponent of its efficacy
expelliarmus is traditionally used to
disarm your opponent
and strip them of their wand it's used
extensively in jewels
but can actually send an opponent flying
through the air if the casting is
particularly powerful
so while it is easy to learn it is
exceptionally useful
and is one of the main reasons that lord
voldemort was defeated when voldemort
cast avada gadavra on harry in the
battle of hogwarts
harry responded with expelliarmus which
he then sent voldemort's avalikadavra
back at him
by the elder one's recognition that
harry was its true master
harry's defeat of voldemort using
expelliarmus was largely circumstantial
but expelliarmus still had a valuable
part to play so while it's not the most
complicated
experiments did prove to be one of the
most significant spells
in this series number two expecto
patronum
this ancient and mysterious charm
conjures a magical guardian
projection of all of your most positive
feelings the patronus charm is difficult
and
many witches and wizards are unable to
produce a full corporeal patronus
a guardian which generally takes the
shape of the animal with whom they share
the deepest affinity
you may suspect but you will never truly
know what form your patronus will take
until you succeed in conjuring it
coming in at number two on the list is
expecto patronum
expecto patronum otherwise known as a
patronus charm
is used to create a protective shield
around a wizard or witch
a patronus charm is produced when a
witch or wizard casts the spell
expecto patronum and it should be noted
that there are two types of patronus
charms
corporeal and incorporeal the more basic
form of the spell
is the incorporeal patronus which
assumes no animal form
and simply resembles a burst of white
vapour or smoke
and the more advanced form of the spell
is the conjuring of a corporeal patronus
the ability to successfully cast a
corporeal patronus is considered a very
impressive feat in the wizarding
community
and casting it is generally the sign of
a powerful witch or wizard
the patronus evokes a positive energy
force considered to be
the spirit guardian of the caster and
the reason that it ranks so high on this
list
is because it is the only known defense
against both dementors
and letterfolds given how many run-ins
harry and other witches and wizards from
the series
have with dementors i think the spell is
basically essential
number one protego in all of its forms
topping the list of defensive spells
today is none other than protego
for me protego makes the top of this
list by a mile and that's because there
are so many different versions of
protego
which in its most basic form is known as
the shield charm
protego regular is a defensive ability
that any witcher wizard should possess
in their magical arsenal
it blocks physical entities reflects
spells and even rebounds conjurations
back towards the caster
it's a great well-rounded defensive
ability but one thing that shouldn't be
overlooked
is that there are six different
variations of this powerful spell
and each version becomes incrementally
stronger than the last
however one thing that should be noted
is the transition from an on-demand
combat based spell
it's more of a protective enchantment
type spell starting with the regular
protego
it goes protego duo proteco totalm
protego maxima
protego herbalis and finally protego
diabolica
protego duo is just a slightly more
advanced form of the regular protego
protego totalim is where things start to
pivot towards more of a protective
shield type of spell
protego maxima is a more powerful
version of protego totalim
protego horribilis is the most powerful
of the traditional protective
shield formats and protego diabolica is
a whole other animal
ever heard the adage the best defense is
a good offense
well protago diabolica is unimaginably
strong in both offensive
and defensive settings it's possibly the
most powerful spell across both harry
potter
and fantastic beasts and we first see it
in the crimes of grindelwald
when the gelat grindelwald casts it
inside the lestrange mausoleum
the spell creates a ring of protective
black fire around the target
and anyone who is an enemy of the caster
will be instantly incinerated when they
try to enter
the circle the shield can also be
controlled like a weapon and the caster
has the capacity to extend 10 drills
of black flames towards enemies anyone
struck by one of these tendrils will
suffer the same fate as someone trying
to enter the circle
and if that isn't enough already the
spell eventually escalates into what can
only be described
as a fiery winged demon with the
capacity to destroy entire cities
though the spell eventually turns into
what could certainly be described as an
offensive ability
it's still a defensive spell at its
roots and that's it for this list
what do you guys think do you agree with
some of these decisions
what would your top five look like let
me know down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
howry